Peggy's 16 a murder of vanishing weapon
the Roman Baths that's for us
Watson Fatah had beautiful plans
good day to you mr. Phillips my name is
Sherlock Holmes and this is my colleague
dr. Watson would you be so kind as to
answer our questions certainly sir
hmm did you receive any other visitors
this morning no one until these
gentlemen are right sir Gregory was the
first did you leave the baths at anytime
or receive any visitors no sir I did not
you are not telling the truth mr.
Phillips you left your work this morning
and you went to the post office where
you dispatched a telegram at around 7:30
but how could you know I the telegram
was for someone in Manchester mr. Holmes
it simple I'll tell you everything
I left the baths at 7:20 my sister wrote
to me yesterday and she needed a reply
or our mother is unwell I was away for
20 minutes and I closed the baths on my
way out
did you check to see if the key was
still in your desk when he returned no I
didn't please mr. Holmes don't tell the
police about this sir Gregory would give
me the sack I need this job
I see